tu es en france à présent marqué par la
ferraille des brides one le crs mis en
cause dans la mort de cet octogénaire
décédée en 2018 ne sera pas sanctionné
et ce malgré l'avis de l'igpn lors de
l'acte iii des gilet jaune à marseille
si les brédois et à sa fenêtre
lorsqu'elle est touché au visage par une
grenade lacrymogène tirée par le
policier en question elle décédera le
lendemain à l'hôpital l' expertise
médicale avait conclu à une mort
accidentelle
le dossier a été classé sans suite par
le directeur général de la police
nationale pour justifier sa décision il
évoque la fatigue du policier le manque
de visibilité à sa tension et la
nécessité légalement établie de tirer
pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec samir redouane le fils aîné de
zineb redouane
s'agirait pas de bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur ar t france alors
on imagine bien sûr votre déception
votre colère à la suite de cette
décision qu'attendez vous aujourd'hui
bonjour tout d'abord vicaire goût
remercier de l'intérêt que vous portez à
notre cause
aujourd'hui je suis vraiment déçu moi et
m'a prescrit
de cette décision du directeur de la
police nationale
alors on sait que
les experts
montrer que la grenade lacrymogène en
tout cas selon de la première expertise
a été tiré dans les règles de l'art un
tir accidentel une enquête
journalistique elle avait conclu à un
autre thèse celle d'un tir tendu où en
est justement cette affaire y at il une
nouvelle contre expertise
oui effectivement
il ya eu une autre contre expertise qui
a démontré
que le tir n'était pas en vrai
l'enquète administratives elles éclosent
maintenant l'information judiciaire à
elle se poursuit les conclusions du
rapport de l'igpn ont été transmis ce
justement au juge d'instruction lyonnais
qui est chargé du dossier de ce que vous
espérez aujourd'hui
bon tout d'abord nous on a vu qu'ils
délivrent notre famille on va déposer
plainte directement du directeur de la
police nationale
et la fête commence on avait ciblé qui
doivent prendre des décisions comme ça
et là pierre giner hong kong moment
justice il a dépassé d'injustice comment
se fait il
que tout sépare
donc la sphère va va continuer
sur ce côté là on sait également que
votre soeur on avait d'ailleurs appelé à
emmanuel macron d'intervenir est ce que
vous avez une réponse de la part de la
présidence
non pas du tout pas du tout oh non même
pas reçu
les condoléances officielles de la
france
est ce qu'être mère était jetée dans son
appartement qu'elle avait des visées
directement elle va bien habiter au
quatrième étage est il non vie les deux
services ont déjà identifié il va
déposer plainte à la cour européenne
on va pas se taire ils cherchent eux
aussi ils ont tué ma mère
il est mort il est c'est pas et pas
juste du tout
alors
votre avocat a réagi justement après
cette décision et finalement il ne
s'attendait pas à grand chose peut être
par rapport à cette procédure concernant
le crs qui est mise en cause dans la
dans le décès de votre maman aujourd'hui
il veut un procès aux assises un procès
pour meurtre c'est ce que vous souhaitez
également
bien sûr bien sûr
comment comment ça fait ni les
directeurs de la police là des possibles
gpn l'ipn exemple ils ont fait 1 qu'
une enquête contraire publie louis
très bien en tout cas merci beaucoup
samir et doit d'avoir réagi ce matin sur
rtl france je rappelle que vous êtes le
fils et des filles deuxième rideau